i got so annoyed when i heard that over
vacation gary alphabetized his vinyl
collection
it just didn't maybe i didn't know that
yeah he was very busy
no i don't [ __ ] out of me why does it
annoy you
why you have so much free time that you
can alphabetize your vinyl collection
what i was on my vacation but of all the
things you could do you alphabetized
your vinyl collection that's like a
teenager does that
it's well it's so big that i wasn't able
to find records so i needed to put them
in a while wow
now that's saying something he's got
like a library
yeah oh gary told everyone it was a very
a very big deal for him
to do that was very it was that's a
quote i thought it was cathartic
it is the dewey decimal system
organization so like what do you do if
you have like
the band are they under t or the other b
oh they're under b right how do you make
that decision and then you get
well the big decision was where to put
uh uh
john cougar mellencamp and if you know
because half the records are john cougar
and then half of them are john cougar
mellencamp but he inevitably went under
m
but you know a purist might have split
the records up i did not do that
where can i find then when you get them
down what about
bon iver or
jefferson it probably goes under b yeah
where does jefferson start
it was a jefferson airplane they're
going to get
wow they were the starship not jefferson
anything
can you imagine what went on and then
when i was filing for prince
i went do i follow on the prince or do i
file it under the symbol
for prince because prince didn't want to
be known as prince
so the symbol should be like at the at
the end of his collection it should just
be like things like the symbol
yes i was so annoyed it's like you know
both are you have no idea if you really
want to get into it
no i don't what what wait a minute come
on
wait a second i think i'm about to
explain the buoy decimal system
they all had dividers so there's
dividers you know for a
b c d i had those and then um you know
there's a section for comedy
uh section for various very phenomenal
what's embarrassing
oh what do i put in various oh mary
excuse me i'll be down for lunch in a
minute but i'm working on my
various and could you bring up a secret
policeman's other ball
concerts for the people you know fred
get his jokes out gary
give him a [ __ ] breathing room to get
the comedy
jesus christ gary's so excited about his
[ __ ] record collection he's more like
fred do you hear that
fred go ahead do i put dixie chicks on
the d
or since they became the chicks do i put
it under
c hmm it was a decision that was an
actual decision
the record i have says dixie chicks on
it that's why i put it under d
yeah but when you get the chicks album
what do you do
what are you going to do
i guess i'll put it under dixie chicks
because that's where the other ones are
and what about your 45s do they get uh
in the collection too or they have a
separate collection
no that's the next project that's a
different project oh he didn't even get
to the 45.
what about something like ue lewis in
the news what do you how do you handle
that gary
i mean it's very obvious it goes under l
what about jay-z his last name is z
oh
you know i don't have any jay-z vinyl
but i can't put
jay-z i geez that's a tough one i don't
know
i mean it would be jay
yeah yeah i mean if you hit a snag you
call me i'll help you out